اهلا بكم في مؤتمر انا عندي 11 سنه للصف
السادس بحب الاشغال اليدويه والرسم ركوب
الباتيناج واكلمكم النهارده عن الكرتون كل
الاطفال بيحبوا الكرتون لانه دايما بيبقى
وسيله ترفيهيه جاذبه للطفل مع انه احيانا
بنلاقي حاجات مش منطقيه خالص
البط بياكل فراخ
بيولع تحت البحر وكمان ما بيحصلوش حاجه
هو ازاي النضاره ما وقعتش من عينيه
في بحر تحت البحر وكمان النار بتولى تحت
البحر
الجاذبيه بتشتغل بس لما تبص تحت
عادي جدا نسمع من عينينا
الاسفنجه بتخسر المواعين بايديها
عادي جدا تبقى سلطعون وتخلف بنت حوت
الفار بيجر كلب
على فكره يا بطوط انت كده كده طول الوقت
مش لابس بنطلون واحنا ساكتين لك
هو ازاي الاكل ما وقعتش من ايديها
الشعر جزء من الجمجمه
حتى هنا عنده ادنى فكره الولد ده بيدخل
التيشرت من راسه ازاي
كل المتجوزين بيبقوا شبه بعض كانهم اخوات
توام
كلبين في نفس الكرتون واحد بيتكلم والثاني
حيوان الاليف
من حق كلب يبقى عنده كلب
رغم ان هو طول الوقت مش لابس هدوم الا
اللي هو بيتكسف وهو بياخد دش بس
السنافر مش راضيه تخرج من السجن
ما بيلبسوش الهدوم الا على البحر بس
هو بيسمع منين
ده بيخلينا نسال سؤال مهم جدا هل من
الممكن ان الكرتون يبقى وسيله تعليميه قبل
ما يبقى وسيله ترفيهيه وهل نقدر من خلاله
نطار مهارات الاطفال انا بحلم لما اكبر
اكون مصممه اصمم شخصيات منطقيه وفيها
ابداع تجذب الاطفال ويكون كرتون له اهداف
يعلمهم التسامح والحب والرحمه وكل الصفات
الحميده والكرتون تاني ويبقى في كرتون
يعلمهم الفنون المختلفه وكرتون للبرمجه
وكرتون للروبوتكس كل ده عن طريق قصص شيقه
ممتعه حبه اصمم شخصيه رياضيه تشجع الاطفال
على الرياضه والحركه
ويبقى في كرتون يعلمهم الحساب واللغات
والنوم المختلفه وكرتون
اول ما اكتشفت جنبي كنت برسم الشخصيات عن
كنت برسم الشخصيات على الورق بعدين بدات
اطور نفسي وصممت شخصيات بسيطه وصممت العاب
ودلوقتي بس بطور نفسي في تصميم الشخصيات
انا بحلم انا بسعى في تحقيق حلمي وقريب
هكون حققت جزء من اهدافي شكرا لاستماعكم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]